hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back at the 1921
vulture championship between Jose raúl
capablanca and Emanuele ask her this is
game nine Capablanca is still in the
lead and congratulations everyone who
figured out that the quote above the
board is actually by Michael Tunnel by a
couple Blanca so there you have it now
I've you know fixed it so everything is
in order now let's check out the game
Blanca with the white pieces opens with
d4 with d5 Knight to f3 philosophy goes
east 6 with c4 and c5 tower defense is
on the board
we have an early trade in the center C
captures he captures Knight to c3 and
Knight to c6 and here a couple bunker
opts for a nice thin cat oink of the
light square bishop so now Bishop to g2
is the plan with knife - f6 Bishop to g2
and now Bishop to e6 and capablanca just
castles here with Bishop to e7 and here
D captures on c5 before developing the
dark square bishop with Bishop captures
and now Bishop to g5 forcing black at
some point a retreat with Bishop to e7
and here Alaska goes for d4 and
Capablanca says that he was not familiar
with this line and he couldn't really
decide whether he wants to go Knight to
e4 just capture on f6 he decided to
capture he decided to go 94 as he
thought it was the safer option he was
unfamiliar with the line capturing
immediately can run into G captures on
f6 and now after 94 you can either go
back to b6 or Bishop to e7 probably
Bishop T stone but it's hard to say what
the last were had in mind and then
there's a lot of imbalance in the
position I know you you're gonna waste a
lot of time in the opening you don't
want to do something like this in a
World Chess Championship match so after
d4 couple Blanca was for a nice night
efore line where he can just trade
everything down and they have a very
safe position so Alaska retreats and
Bishop to e7 here you can't go Bishop to
b6 and claim that it's the same line as
the previous one because here why
doesn't capture here white plays Queen
to c1 and now black will have a very
hard time there's a lot of pressure
the the c6 night here you can't really
castle the safety and it's hard to
decide what to do here for black for
example if you Castle it's a game over
immediately just Bishop captures and
well not that obviously but after you
capture the Bishop Queen to h6 there's
no defense against Knight f6 check and
Queen Queen h7 checkmate one of the the
examples so here Knight back the e7 by
Lasker and now Knight captures an f6
couple Blanca nicely trades everything
down with Bishop captures the Bishop
captures Queen captures and now Blanca
says that he doesn't like blacks
position here especially the the you
know advance the d4 pawn but he doesn't
have a clear way of punishing the
position so he goes Queen to a4 it's a
nice idea still you're pressuring the
pawn here you're pressuring this point
if for example the rook moves maybe you
can capture the knight and snatch the a
7-point also couple Monica has ideas of
going Queen b5 with an attack on the b7
pawn and Queen g5 where he can force the
Queen trade not allow Lasker any any
activity Lasker just castles now the
knight is no longer pinned and here
while you could go rooks LeSabre case
you wanna look FD one or or FC one just
develop a route Capablanca still goes
for his Queen to b5 so now the b b7
point is under attack and or you could
defend or you could maybe play something
like rook to d8 and then if couple are
kaput captures maybe then you can go
rook b8 but there's still the problem of
the night see that will be undefended if
you allow the capture on b7 so
rook 8 the b8 better than rook F to be
it if you play rook F to b8 then okay
the rooks will be like this and then
it's hard to say what you will do with
your a eight rook so look 88 keeping an
eye on the b7 pawn and here rook F to d1
now capablanca continues development he
still didn't go for a queen to g5 but
now Oscar prevents it now last replace H
6 and now Capablanca no longer can offer
a queen trade here well rather force a
queen trade and now Knight the e1
Capablanca wants to now Riemann over the
night and also now he frees the
light-square bishop
where there is a maybe the threat of
capturing the the knight on c6 but last
verse says it's not a problem just rook
fe8 he's ready to put pressure on the e2
pawn maybe with Bishop to g4 and here
Capablanca says that capturing the night
only leads to a draw because if you
capture on c6 you get B captures and c6
Queen captures on c6 and now rook ec8
you force the Queen back Queen to f3 and
now Alaska would you just capture and b2
and here after this trade it's not a
problem black will have a somewhat
messed up pawn structure here but also
last we will have a lot of activity with
the rooks for example if you try and
untangle your e to bone is under attack
maybe we want to play Knight f3 go after
the pawn but then d3 is the possibility
and after rook captures you can capture
Ani - tonight we'll come to d4 at some
point but you're gonna have to keep it
there or black will be able to activate
both rooks and on the second-ranked and
it's hard to imagine that white will be
able to do anything here so after look f
e8 we've looked at b2 by Capablanca now
keeping an eye on everything here on the
second rank and the last pair now goes
Bishop to g4 puts more pressure on the e
du Pont also the rook is now free to
roam the e-file with rook the c1 now
putting more pressure to the C file and
now rook to e4 Alaska prevents
capablanca from playing rook to c5 and
here he tries to trick capablanca into
going group the c5 Capablanca played
Queen to d3 but here if you go rook the
c5 seems like a reasonable idea I mean
why not it actually loses the game for 4
kappa blanka so feel free to pause the
video here and try to figure out what
last we had in mind in this position
while I give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
maneuver of Queens and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
Queen to g5 this is what last we had in
mind and now the straight forward rook
captures on e5 obviously loses the Queen
captures on d2 now threatening the night
here but it's not so simple the
variation continues Bishop captures on
c6 now okay you're you freed the G to
square for King Queen captures only
on with check King to g2 and now you
cannot capture here because the rook on
b8 is hanging but what you can play and
what Lasker saw is a six now the Queen
has to remain on the B file to keep an
eye on the rook so you have to play
something like Queen to b3 and now d3
wins the game really just insane but
also it's still not that simple the
variation still goes on rook d7
threatening Queen captures on f7
following Queen captures on g7 with mate
so now comes a rogue f8 the rook is no
longer here so you will be able to
capture on c6 but now what do you do you
still can't you still can't capture the
pawn as your Bishop is hanging you
always have to keep an eye on the bishop
so you have to move it Bishop to f3 and
now b2 is winning again because the
bishop guards the d7 square no rook d7
is possible and next move black bow just
get a queen into the game so your best
bet is Bishop captures but then once you
get a queen in three game you have a
queen and rook against the bishop and
rook of course completely winning for
kappa blanka the idea after rook the c5
is that sorry after Queen to g5 is that
Capablanca can't play rugby the c2 now
getting more firepower here under C C
file but it still doesn't work because
of Bishop captures I need to and now
rook captures on e5 Bishop captures on
b5 rook captures on g5 and tau H
captures on g5 look the c5 attacking the
bishop and the pawn here but now d3
where of course if you capture the
bishop then d2 and you cannot stop
promotion you will either play d1 Queen
or D captures on e one Queen so you can
prevent both squares and if you don't
capture it what else can you play you
could play Knight to f3 just keep an eye
on the DT square but then a6 defending
the bishop you're gonna play rook e8
rook rook E - you're gonna play upon 2 D
- and still it's gonna be a very
difficult position for white to defend
so this is what Lasker had in mind when
he offered kappa blanka the blunder the
game with rook c5 but Capablanca is not
interested after all he did not
challenge Alaska for the title to
blunder games like this we have Brooke
beat
I ate now Alaska occupies the e file and
now comes Bishop to f3 and here Alaska
has a couple of options maybe maybe
there's a page three is possible it
seems like Moo that really just over
complicates things doesn't really
achieve anything something maybe tal
would play or maybe you could try h5
here to keep the attack going but here
after couple Blancas a Bishop to f3
Alaska played Bishop captures on f3 and
it was in fact in this position that the
players agreed to a draw unmoved 21 it
seems like there's a lot going on on the
board but really there isn't
after you trade everything down it's a
it's a very simple draw end game which
which can happen after well now White
has to recapture let's say Knight
captures you attack the rook we have
looked for now defending the d4 pawn but
now look the c-4 again attacking it and
now you play Queen e6 and everything
simply unwinds Knight captures you will
have nightcap person before rook
captures on d4 rook captures any two
captures you will have captures captures
and captures and now you have the same
game where both players have a rook and
five points and the position is
basically identical so this is a this is
a completely drawn endgame you can
either go Ruby for to defend or you can
go look the a4 to start attacking blacks
pawns but all in all this is a complete
draw so after Bishop Bishop f3 and
Bishop capture Sun f3 of course both
couple Lanka and last who knew that and
they decided to draw the game so yeah
this is game 9 we could say ah calm
before the storm
Coco Blanc are still leading one point
in the match and well last but we'll
have to figure out how to how to come at
a couple Lanka what did the white pieces
in game 10 yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it also I would like to
thank build a near Frank Holmes
Pablo Mohan Andres la sauce and crispy
card for attribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it and
also I would like to wish a happy
birthday to Tom summer may you win many
chess games and well most of all be sure
to enjoy chess at all times
so as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon continuing the
Capablanca saga checking up in our
suggestions as I already have a few very
lovely suggestions so thank you for that
and checking up what's you know going on
in the chess world thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day